[Music]
in the past two years the media have
adopted a new principle if someone is
connected to the current administration
that person can be targeted for
destruction for any reason or no reason
at all and it's all virtuous because the
president is evil well until last month
David Sorenson was a speechwriter in the
White House and then the Washington Post
accused him of domestic violence now why
did they do this because of the word of
his ex-wife Sorensen lost his job he
says the post had no evidence that he
ever did anything wrong the post had no
court records no police report no
evidence no pictures nothing and now his
life has been destroyed David Sorenson
joins us tonight with his story David I
want to say at the outset that we've
never met I've never spoken in my life
before this I don't know anything about
your marriage I don't even know your
ex-wife's name but what struck me about
this story normally I would never get
involved in ething like this because I
know that these things would tend to be
really complicated but what struck me
about this story was you say the post
had literally no evidence no actual
evidence you've done anything wrong
that's right Tucker and first of all
these accusations are completely false
and fabricated I've never been violent
in any way toward any woman in my entire
life the very thought of is disgusting
to me it's not the way it was raised the
post nonetheless and their ongoing war
against President Trump decided to
publish a story based on my ex-wife's
word alone that I was physically violent
during our marriage and they had no
evidence I've never had a police report
against me for violence I've never had a
restraining order against me and the
three of her friends even came out
people I hadn't spoken with in years and
said that she was had a history of
instability and dishonesty and that they
shouldn't believe her in that they
actually witnessed her being violent
against me it's violent against you
she was actually and I sent the post and
every other media outlet that asked a 13
page document as soon as I was accused
full of text message and photo evidence
documenting her violence against me she
never brought this up in our divorce a
divorce which I initiated by the way
there's there's simply nothing but our
word to go on and it's really shameful
in the post part but you say
had documentary' evidence that she was
the perpetrator of violence did the post
run that evidence not that I'm aware of
no not that I recall they said that I
alleged it she actually admitted to it
she admitted to it in text messages and
she admitted to it and in subsequent
interviews with the media I actually had
a reporter one time during all of this
and by the way I spoke to every reporter
I could I was very transparent and I had
two reporter say to me what no
acknowledging that she was violent
toward me and and that that was an
established fact say well you know we
heard that you said some pretty nasty
things during your marital fights and I
couldn't imagine a reporter saying the
same thing to a woman who's whose
husband hadn't had admittedly been
violent to order what was the name of
double standard which reporter was that
who said that this was from a local TV
station up in Maine
where I was working before my job that's
pretty shocking so I guess the obvious
question is if there if your wife
ex-wife admitted using violence against
you and there's evidence that she did
you deny that you used violence against
her there's no evidence that you did why
did you lose your job well because I
worked for a president Trump in the
White House that's that's all there is
to it I don't think it's even a question
whether that story would have run if I
didn't work there and president Trump
thank God for him at least his is
calling out the media for their ongoing
bias like few people are but you know on
top of all that Tucker from my part I
passed a polygraph exam proving my
innocence
the sitting governor of a state my
former boss Governor LePage of me and
offered me my job back you had that much
faith in me virtually everybody we both
knew came out publicly and said we don't
believe her and they had total faith in
me it's just it's just it's any more
one-sided thing well it certainly are
well Ian and I think you're probably not
alone in this this is the first time
we've dug down in one of these stories
in which you find is pretty upsetting
David thank you for telling us your
story I appreciate it
Thank You Tucker